the jurogan experience yeah i did all
that
i went outside and i started taking it
and i lost weight i didn't want to and i
haven't gotten it
good but aren't you happy you lost
weight do you feel like lighter i
feel lighter that's exactly how i feel
around yeah
dude well it's like it's the equivalent
of like eight bags of potatoes and if i
think about what it would be like to
carry that around in a backpack
like through an airport and then you get
to set it down okay one of those take
one with 45 pound plates
that's a heavy [ __ ] weight like yeah
you put on like a
barbell one of those big ones that's
what you lost
my ankle weights and my hand weights
together are
20 pounds and if i think about carrying
that times two
even across a room i would
i would be tired and that's what you
were doing and i feel so much
better i mean i had had back pain from
the time that i was a teenager i'd had
joint pain
and i thought that i was just gonna have
it for my whole life because i didn't
think i was heavy enough that it was
affecting
my joints and that pain is all gone and
um and it makes sense to me because
again if i carry around a heavy bag
through an airport like my back will
hurt at the end of the day if i do that
right now
yeah and to have to carry that weight
around everywhere i go
everything i do even just sitting having
that extra weight
like i just don't want it back and i
think part of it might be because i
stopped eating flour and sugar which
i've heard are inflammatory as well so i
think part of it might be that but
the other thing is just getting to set
down the weight i feel awesome
i think both are factors yeah for sure i
mean definitely
it's just logical that the weight's a
factor but for sure sugar
and and flour and any processed foods
like that
cause inflammation so what did you do
for exercise
um i play tennis and swim
and i do workouts that stacia patwell
created
she was a comic she ran a show at the
store and she's
a trainer and she started doing these
classes on
zoom for female comics and a bunch of us
have had
before and after transformations
where like a bunch of fat comics have
gotten hot because of
her workouts she's onto something dude
she's so [ __ ] funny and she
can like work you out for an hour where
i'm just like laughing i feel like i'm
hanging out with a friend
and she has this specific brand of tough
love where she'll like
she'll call she'll call me a [ __ ] like
right before i'm about to drop out of a
plank and she'll be like the world has
enough [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] out what is her name again
stacia patwell
s-t-a-s-i-a-p-a-t-w does she have an
instagram
yeah and her instagram is just that it's
all one word jamie will find it
she's a [ __ ] monster and she called
her things school of
thought t-h-o-t johnson that's hilarious
school of thought a beast
dude is that her right there yeah she
has the transformations in her
highlights
all right she's so [ __ ] funny dude
she's
nostalgic for boston in the 90s right
now yeah
she'll yell at you and her like long
island accent
and something about it i wouldn't
tolerate half the [ __ ] she says to me
from better than east coast in the 90s
i'm telling you some of that wasn't
funny
oh there i am look at that oopsy doopsy
bitsy's in a bra uh-oh
go to the far right look at her dude you
lost so much weight that's crazy
got my little cats in the background
that i adopted so i wouldn't
open my wrists in a bathtub there we go
there she is
i did not know i was that fat boy do i
have egg on my face
what what did you think i thought i had
25 pounds to lose and so i set
i mean i'm comfortable talking about
numbers so my top weight was 180
i set my goal weight at 155 and now i'm
142.5 wow and i'm not
i'm in a healthy weight range so if my
body stops like easily losing weight
then i'll be like okay this is the
weight that my body wants to be
but it's still i'm still losing weight
and it's not
protesting i'm certainly not starving
myself that's awesome
yeah so it was just a matter of eating
the right food and just
forcing yourself to do rigorous exercise
yeah i joined a support group for
overeaters
and i weigh measure and write down every
single thing i put in my body
and eat balanced portions that were
given to me by
a dietitian so i measure out like
protein
grains fruits and vegetables fats and
then
my goal that i um that i try for
is to be in a caloric deficit of about
250 calories a day which averages out to
about a half a pound a week of weight
loss
and i don't do it perfectly but like
that's enough where
i'm not starving all the time i'm
satiated
but so it's sustainable but i'm also
like steadily losing weight
and it's been i mean i haven't had pizza
in
a year like i haven't had any added
flour any added sugar
wow in um like 10 months well you're a
disciplined person you know i really
admire your work ethic and i
i know i've told you this before because
you would come to the store with your
notebooks i'm like look at you your
notebook is like
you're [ __ ] like meticulous like all
your [ __ ] would be like super written
out and
so many comics are so impulsive
and sort of scatterbrained and they
don't focus
and i really admire that you're focused
i always admired that i thought it was
cool
thank you so much i admire that about
you too so that means so much coming
from you i admire your work ethic yeah i
pretty much like took the energy that i
had been putting into stand-up and just
applied that same
thing to this because it's like if you
really want to do something
why [ __ ] around why waste the effort
like what would be the point
and i spent so long trying to like diet
without
weighing and measuring and having like
an intention that it's like i just put
up a shitload of boundaries to where it
was
unfuck-uppable because i believe in
taking like
little actions in the direction of the
thing that you want but it doesn't help
me if i'm like
i'm going to try to just eat better
which is such a general
concept and then if i'm stepping on the
scale once a week
then what happens when my weight is up
because as it stands now i'll step on
the scale my weight could be up three
pounds
and that's fine and i don't trip because
i wrote everything down
i know that i'm in a caloric deficit and
i know it's water or
salt whatever i don't understand that
stuff but
then i step on the scale the next week
and it'll be down you know
and so i thought that like a weight loss
chart
went like that but it really goes like
that and i think especially for women i
mean mine's just been up down up down up
down but the general trend is
you know if you can take the energy
that you like the good that you feel
from losing weight and get getting
healthy and just
somehow another like put it in a vr like
put it in someone's head like
feel just [ __ ] feel this just feel
this ready put it on like oh my god i
feel so good like you can get there
you can get there like you can get there
but the problem is everybody wants to
get there so quick
they want to get there immediately they
want to take a pill they want to listen
to dr oz
they want to get there quick you can't
[ __ ] get there quick yeah it doesn't
work
and that the crazy thing is like you got
to get
sick the same way or you got to get
better the same way you got sick
like it takes time to get overweight and
it takes time to lose weight
like you if you're not going to just
starve yourself and lose at all because
your body's going to go in a deficit
you're going to freak out
your metabolism is going to crash then
when you eat you're going to pack it on
quick because your body's getting like
oh my god
we we might starve to death like i have
to slow my metabolism down
yeah i think a huge part of it too is
like the action has to be the reward
so like i love doing my workouts because
she makes me laugh
it's built right into my routine i eat
my oatmeal
i meditate and then i do one of her
workouts and it
it feels good it feels good for my body
and um and the same thing with food like
i don't eat most of my favorite foods
from before
anymore but i love everything i do eat
because i've learned how to cook stuff
brown rice vegetables proteins i've
learned how to cook food the way that
it tastes good to me and so i'm not
doing workouts i hate i'm not eating
food that i hate
and so it's sustainable
that's awesome i throw this off you got
crazy got a little crazy it's
sustainable
everybody gets electrocuted yeah it's uh
it's good to see
i'm very happy for you catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience